it's acc basketball a conference game
open up the year here on tobacco road
one of the top freshmen in the country
[Applause]
again
[Applause]
that was pretty impressive to say the
least i'm gonna be happy about it a
little bit tonight give myself a little
pat on the back
but uh we got practice tomorrow we gotta
fly back in we got game on friday
this dude straight blew up in this first
game dropping 34 on the irish
of course cole anthony came in as the
highest rated point guard in the country
but when you put up those numbers in
power to blue
expectations follow well i think that a
lot of players that we've had that chose
to come here is because the history the
tradition
we attract the kind of kids who can lose
themselves into the team
a young man can come here to try to win
a national championship
and also be able to reach his own
individual dreams and goals
there's a really rich tradition in unc i
mean
we've been several good teams that have
come through here a lot of nba players
have come through here as well
so i mean it's just that legacy that we
just have to carry for many years i've
thought the biggest adjustment for a
high school kid to a college kid
playing at the acc particularly is that
your
level of intensity has to be really
really high and it's got to stay up
there
and take pride in competing
and take pride every day and being able
to play your best regardless of who
you're playing
[Applause]
the tar heels jumped out to six and one
and number six in the country
tony was set the path laid out another
dominant unc
squad in the making coming into the
season i thought we were going to be a
pretty good team i thought we're going
to have a chance to win an actual title
but i mean i wasn't expecting to get
injured cole anthony out with a knee
injury partially torn meniscus
he is listed as out indefinitely now
you're looking at a team that
is without co-anthony for the next four
to six years without him how many games
are they going to be able to win
unc it's in a lot of hurt here they've
seen better days in chapel hill
when i first heard that cole got hurt we
didn't think it was quite that
significant
and then all of a sudden it comes back
he's going to have to have surgery
so your first concern is how is he going
to handle the surgery
how is he going to bounce back how is he
going to be with it
i mean when they first told me that i
just broke down i just started crying
i was just thinking that i just wanted
to play with my brothers play with
everyone on this team
i thought i had more to give so just it
hurt me that i wasn't able to be out
there with them
i'm not trying to be alarmist but no
cole anthony if i'm a unc
fan i have real concern about even
making the tournament this year unc
desperately needs cole anthony back to
get on track
our conversations once he was injured
his son you're gonna be all right
this has happened to other good players
and they've come back very well from it
let's just take it a day at a time take
the rehab a day at a time work at it
be cold give it everything you have and
let's see what happens
even acl tears you know guys come back
100 this was a meniscus
we've seen this all the time when guys
come back 100
i was happy to hear that he did come
back because a lot of guys would have
tried to preserve their draft stock
you know shut it down the second the
injury happened and i think that really
speaks to cole's
mentality that he's a competitor he
wants to play he wants to win games
[Applause]
a lot of people were telling me i
shouldn't come back but i just thought
the best way to get better at playing
basketball is just to gain experience
[Applause]
even with cold back the struggles of the
season were real
unc had fallen out of the ranks and
their season was spiraling
and to compound it they dropped the next
four in a row
[Music]
from the dean smith virginia and unc
we get ready for this matchup good
atmosphere here tonight
they're good how are y'all all right
this place is incredible
22 23 000. this city
chapel hill revolves around the
university obviously the basketball
program you've got a
one of the greatest coaches ever and
rory williams
when you have an opportunity to be a
part of something like this
this will be with you for the rest of
your life
the defending national champs are in the
house
anthony jumped gold anthony with a three
the aquitay hangs hits and one
[Applause]
and virginia escapes with a big win
i saw going i said i wanted to cry i
ain't gonna lie to you i wanted to cry
it's really deflating but the end of the
day our season's not over we're gonna
keep our heads high we have a game
monday we're going to come up with some
fire on monday
and we're going to lock in he needed
this
and coach williams told him you know
this is probably the most difficult
year of his short life and the reason
it's going to be really good for him
because it's made him
have to reevaluate
and to make fundamental changes
he comes in obviously as the top player
you hand the keys to him as
a freshman point guard and acc i don't
think people realize how difficult that
is
yeah i mean north carolina i mean
they're always a team that's expected to
go to the final four the bar is kind of
higher for a guy like cult
particularly given his high school
accolades and then again
the prestigious north carolina you'd
expect
wins
[Applause]
and another turnover by north carolina
what you can take from adversity is just
how you handled it
and i tell them that's the way it is in
life you can't just uh roll up into a
fetal position go in the corner and
start crying for your mama
you got to come play and you got to try
to get better every single day
this is probably my first losing season
it's my whole life so i mean i've said
this before this has been
one of the hardest years i've had
playing basketball
comes in the morning gonna take my time
what's mine again the game's like
if it's later we'll typically get up and
go do something just to get active but
if we have like we've had some early
games in the past we would just sleep in
and go straight to shoot around but
the game's not until eight so everybody
just go get some breakfast now
and then we got some time after that so
i probably
told my lady to pinch me man this
couldn't be real how long i just tweet
i'm at a special restaurant can you send
me ten dollars
you doing anything please man thank you
all right i'm gonna call you back
oh yeah that's the way no bro we're
winning tonight but i don't care
bro remember how we had kobe playing
defense last year on the usa team
yeah we gotta start playing that type of
defense bro that's a lot i don't care
but we just we just got to win bro
i just need one that's gonna get all of
our confidence back bro for real
we just need one
[Music]
most difficult part this year has to be
just losing all these games when we just
we know we're better than this
i mean
we know we're a better team than this
and it's just been really deflating
really frustrating just to be in these
close games and end up losing them at
the buzzer
i might been we've probably had four or
five games this whole year where we've
just lost at the buzzer which is just
super unlucky but at the same time we
can't lose hope
two hours before the game walk over and
there'll be a huge crowd of people just
waiting to get in
this is like two hours before game time
so that joint is crazy
i just want to help my team get some
wins that's all i want to do for them
just feel like
i owe them a lot more i can play a lot
better and just help my team get wins
dean smith center in chapel hill north
carolina for a rivalry game
between the tar heels and north carolina
state
it ain't been going well so i'm gonna
switch it up i'm gonna just rep the hat
tonight
and go in here and root our tar heels on
the victory we hope
this year has been more stressful
than any year since he was in middle
school
because it's the first time where he's
had to deal with
collective and individual disappointment
so you know for your child
you you want it so bad for him and i
know how badly he wants it
and you know the way we've lost so many
games it's been
it's been frustrating i'll tell you it
takes a toll man i'll be honest
man we got to get a dub tonight this
team is 10
and 17. cole anthony
[Applause]
and north carolina has secured the end
[Applause]
[Music]
all right be good be safe i'll talk to
you tomorrow all right
the wind felt good happy for the team
was happy that we could always get this
feeling that's my
actually my first win since before my
injury since
2019. so felt good felt good
[Music]
no one saw this coming but if north
carolina wants any chance at the big
dance
they'll need to win the acc tournament
this is the largest deficit that north
carolina's faced at any time this season
he got out hustle got out classed got
out fought
stairs of disbelief on the carolina
bench it's really been a season all year
long it's been hard to believe
to my expectations that we had a lot of
new guys coming in
i thought we had a chance to be good but
we were going to have to stay healthy
i've never had a losing record in my
life and so it's something that i'm not
very happy with to say the least
i remember telling coach williams uh i
said you know this is it's been a
a strange year you know him getting hurt
all the other injuries that we've had
uh just everything that could have gone
wrong did go wrong but i said to him
that you know if we had that experience
a year like this
i wouldn't want him to have experienced
it anywhere else other than north
carolina
it's been the most difficult basketball
season for me and my entire staff much
less our kids but i think we've sort of
gotten
a little bit of strength from each other
this is a long
journey and there are always going to be
bumps in the road
and the key is that you can learn from
those experience appreciate them
and hopefully those experiences will
allow you
to become a better person and a player
moving forward cole may have been
shaking but he wasn't broken
however the future for him was suddenly
murky i'm not going to
going back to college for another year
that's that's not going to happen
i mean that was never honestly in the
picture we're gonna answer the draft
the wait is over cole anthony announced
today he's going pro
i don't think there are words to
describe like just how this moment feels
to me so i'm just
really excited to work towards my dreams
and aspirations i mean i love carolina
nothing against the school love them i
just feel like this is the best
move for me just in terms of my journey
it was time for cole to put caroline in
the review
focus on the bigger dream but even he
didn't know what was to come